a little bit about myself I run the data
science team at c2fo and before I get
into creating a contemporary risk
management system I have to give you a
little bit of background about c2fo so
that it makes sense kind of in context
so c2fo stands for collaborative cash
flow optimization try to say that ten
times fast good luck but basically we're
the world's first market for working
capital so what does that really mean I
like to give this example where you take
a company like Amazon who happens to be
one of our buyers and Amazon has
hundreds of thousands of suppliers in
their supply chain right so say I'm one
of those suppliers and Amazon bought ten
million dollars worth of t-shirts from
me well typically terms of payment for
such a thing would be 30 60 or 90 days
but if I'm that supplier and I wanted to
get paid early maybe I need to start a
new factory a hire some additional staff
or make some other type of capital
investment I would have to go to a bank
or what's known as a factor ER and
basically you take a big discount on the
nose something to the tune of 15 to 18
percent well what if that same day
Amazon is sitting on five billion cash
and simply looking to make a 7% rate of
return
we can match the two up in the
marketplace and it ends up being a
really cool win-win scenario where the
buyer is achieving their desired rate of
return and that supplier is getting
their lowest cost of capital available
to them one that they name the rate to
four so yeah we have some you know
marketing type pictures here that help
explain that too but when you think
about this problem on a global scale
there's about 38 trillion dollars locked
up in this accounts payable accounts
receivable conundrum so when you think
about if we were able to unleash you
know that that capital the trickle-down
effects that it can have on the world
economy is pretty profound so what I'm
actually going to be focusing on today
is this notion of WFC or water for
commerce it's an investment fund that we
recently started and you know it's
geared towards small to midsize
businesses basically we use some of the
c2fo data to underwrite these
to underwrite these suppliers because we
know so much about them we've been
receiving invoices on them for the
better part of five years on a nightly
basis so if you think about that versus
like a static quarterly you know balance
sheet or cash flow statement you know
that the speed at which and the the
level of granularity that we have this
data is just not comparable to you know
conventional underwriting strategy for
investors it also offers a very
attractive risk profile because we're
looking at something like a forty day
duration with about you know six and a
quarter percent yield which is which is
very exciting for some people so just in
case that wasn't crystal clear
I drew this picture where here you have
the c2fo market you know let's just say
this buyer one here is amazon and you
have this supplier maybe amazon receives
20% of that suppliers you know AP or or
AR from the supplier standpoint but then
they're also doing business with let's
call this a walmart a target and maybe
you know like a Dillard's or something
so right now c2fo cannot help them with
this additional AR over here but that's
where WFC stands in because if they can
upload these invoices from these
out-of-network buyers then we can use
some of the c2fo data to underwrite them
why would we want to do this so you guys
have heard about the Lending Club you
know the prospers the they're a dime a
dozen small to mid-sized business
lenders out there so why are we going
through this trouble of getting into
this very competitive very crowded space
well we think because we can kind of do
it better with some of the data that we
have you guys are familiar with the
adage that better data often beats more
sophisticated algorithms within a
machine-learning context and it can be
that generalization applies in other
areas too c2fo we also like to think of
ourselves as the champion of the
supplier you know helping out those
small to midsize businesses grow also
helps the buyers supply chain and you
know that's ultimately
what we're there to do we can do this
without rate gouging borrowers that's
super important when you look at some of
the APRs that are being charged some of
these suppliers on some of the other
platforms in some cases they're quite
unreasonable and we can do this with
offering a whole lot of transparency for
the investors but none of this would be
at all possible without some of the
great open source tools that we've used
to kind of engineer this system so I
call this slide the sticker table it
should look really familiar if you guys
have been out there to the sticker table
but projects like handus iPod ask stats
models are PI - you know anaconda
matplotlib Luigi you guys can can read
the rest none of this would be possible
frankly without those great tools so now
we're kind of at this point where we
need to understand a little bit about
risk management so I've kind of broken
down this continuum of risk management
will kind of go from left to right I'll
talk about the type of lending risk that
we're addressing and the particular you
know tools and methodologies that we've
used to kind of mitigate that that part
of risk so we'll start with
concentration risk so we think about a
given supplier right all other things
being equal you should much rather
prefer lending to a supplier that has
accounts receivable coming from two
three four five ten buyers as opposed to
one so we can think about this as
concentration risk so you see here you
know the little you know pandas foo and
stacked area chart action over time we
can get these nice pretty visualizations
of course using the latest and greatest
color maps from for matplotlib but C is
more of an ideal scenario than a because
you can see that you know they're a are
is coming in from a host of different
places there's also this notion of junk
that we can think about so you're
familiar with junk bond ratings so when
a supplier is getting paid from buyers
that are of a higher caliber that we do
not deem junk or the street does not
deem junk then that will help out their
score
inevitably as well so you know let's
pick on a payless shoes for example
getting paid you know having 10 million
come in the door from Payless Shoes
three weeks from now is a whole lot
different from a Costco right so moving
on to default risk and this is kind of
you know the biggest part the biggest
hardest part that we need to address
what is default risk it's the likelihood
that somebody is not going to pay you
you know over the course of the lending
agreement so in order to address that
piece we use the five to six years worth
of daily invoice data that we have on
the c2fo markets to create these really
granular forecasts for what a given
supplier is going to have coming in the
door 30 60 90 days from now so that we
can use what we know that they're going
to have coming in to kind of offset you
know the amount that we're comfortable
lending them over that same duration so
Python has the PI data ecosystem has
come a really long way
over the last you know five years but
for those of you out there you know the
economy traditions the economists that
have been doing forecasting for you know
maybe maybe two decades or so you know
there are just some things that did not
exist in the the Python world that have
been kind of battle-tested in the our
world for a while so we look to kind of
use some of those those packages and you
know over time this project started
about a year and a half ago so over time
even the last year and a half those
projects in Python have come a really
long way but things like you know
autoregressive moving average is
although regressive integrated moving
averages rima models exponential
smoothing we also have been using
Bayesian structural time series quite a
bit lately which is quite fantastic and
simple you know OLS and polynomial
regression when applicable but in order
to use those are packages within the
context of our big Python pipeline that
we orchestrate with Luigi we need to we
need to use our PI too so that we could
pandas dataframes to our data frames or
our time series and apply some of those
models I'd also like to point out that
we're evaluating pi flux as well right
now which is a really exciting project
so what does that end up looking like
here you can see a supplier that
exhibits a very very clear seasonal
pattern and you can see the forecast
that we make over the next 90 days of
the next quarter to the right or yeah to
the right you can see one of our back
tests so what we'll do is you know
pretend like we couldn't see the last 90
days
fit a model and then compare that models
performance to the actuals one of the
requirements is that we have at least
five quarters worth of data to fit on
and basically you know we're looking at
things like you know the MAPE and the
RMS C to decide hey which one is the
best model because I went through that
laundry list of different forecast
models before but how do you know that a
Rhema and an ARIMA is more suitable than
a Bayesian structural time series over
you know just the no less regression so
those are the types of things that we
look at during this whole best model
strategy process and then the one that
minimizes the MAPE and the RMS C will
promote to the forecast that ends up
forecasting the next quarter so here you
can see an example of a supplier that
has an invoice pattern that's like a
metronome right these guys are so
predictable they have this very very
repeatable invoicing pattern and down
here you can see a very repeatable
adjustment pattern as well so when I
talk about invoices generally speaking
I'm talking about a positive inflow what
I'm talking about
adjustments I'm talking about a negative
outflow and you see this sort of fancy
sort of cool matplotlib plot here and
you know I really like matplotlib for
you know as some times that the API can
be a bit unruly if you're not using like
a pandas or a seaborne but at the same
time it's also really extensible and you
can do really cool things like you know
throwing these annotations and subplots
galore and you know I really
and we use a lot so another thing that
we need to think about when we talk
about you know default risk mitigation
here is this this concept of seasonality
right we can see here that this
particular supplier has exhibited some
some growth over time you know and
that's kind of broken down into this
into this trend component here and they
also exhibit very regular-season ality
that I liken to a metronome before which
is broken down in this seasonal
component and then kind of everything
that you have left over is that residual
that can't be captured in those two
other pieces but when we're talking
about lending we need to know are they
is this supplier right at the beginning
of a big seasonal period where there aar
is going to be on the steady incline or
they kind of headed towards a trough
right now so breaking down that
seasonality and understanding where they
are in that cycle is really important
for us now I'm going to talk about this
idea of a our discontinuation later on
I'll contrast it with this notion of
bankruptcy but you know this is where we
are for the moment so when I talk about
AR discontinuation think about like
flatlining at the hospital right your
pulse you just cease - your heart stops
beating when we think about cash flow
with the buyers and the c2fo network
that's what I'm considering AR
discontinuation here the likelihood that
it will completely flat line across all
of those buyers in a given duration of
time so in modeling that out it's not
super easy
you know the whole 80/20 rule bla bla
bla with data preparation we needed to
be very sure that we weren't having any
data leakage effectively what you have
to do is go back and say okay if we
wanted to predict this on this date
realistically you know in order to not
get into a lending agreement with a
supplier that may be up to 90 days you
need to know 90 days before that what
the likelihood of them discontinuing
invoicing would be so you have to kind
of chop off that history prior to the
date that you would want that you would
be making a loan and then train your
models based on that that truncated
history
so we were very very cognizant to this
data leakage problem along the way and
then briefly you know talking about
engineering interesting features I like
to think about a feature engineering in
this context kind of three different
ways you can create these really
interesting you know aggregate stats
kind of based on their entire history
you know what was their median this
they're men that they're max this or you
know then you can think about over a
certain recent window like maybe a 13
week window or something like that
calculating all of the same stats and
then maybe you want to look at what was
it right at that point of time that you
would have wanted to make that
prediction oftentimes when you break
apart the future importances and you
know start introspecting some of these
models you'll see that it's an
interesting mix of you know these
historical features these near real-time
features and some of these windowed
features that kind of bubble up to the
top so you know I just encourage you
guys to explore you know different
windows and things like that during your
feature engineering process in the
future so how do we do all this I used
psych it most for most of the future
engineering for things like encoding
categoricals and creating polynomial
features in addition to scaling features
and reducing that feature space using
dimensionality reduction in feature
selection techniques as far as the
models were concerned you know we had a
host of different models that we tested
but you know shocker XG boost ended up
outperforming the majority of them so XT
boost and implementation of gradient
boosted trees very performant machine
learning classifier yada yada yada
we there is a talk just a second ago
next door and to talk yesterday it kind
of touched on you know grid searching
your hyper parameters but when we used
XG boost we were using the hyperope
library to optimize that at hyper
parameter grid search and we're also
currently in the process of evaluating a
library called Spearman that does some
Bayesian optimization there as well so
I'm really excited to kind of get into
get into that as well so when the rubber
hits the road how this thing do we're
really concerned with two things in
training these air discontinuation model
namely recall so what percentage of
those ones that actually ended up
flatlining did we end up catching and
you can kind of see in this plot how the
performance has generally improved over
time some days it goes down a little bit
this big dip here is explained by some
new features that I ended up adding
which drastically improved the
performance of the model and not
overfitting so you know I could give a
whole talk about overfitting but when
you're using a classifier like like a
gradient boosted trees or something like
that you really really need to
understand this overfitting problem and
make sure you're not doing it so that's
a are discontinuation cool got it we
don't want those suppliers to flatline
but then there's this other problem
about bankruptcy so when you think about
bankruptcy
you know sometimes somebody can file for
chapter 11 and they continue to pay
their bills sometimes they file and then
they don't sometimes they file because
their management team had a big falling
out sometimes they file for because you
know the their business just just wasn't
viable so it's kind of a different thing
versus ceasing to invoice with a
particular buyer versus some other type
of nuclear event that caused them to
throw their hands in the air and say we
can't can't pay so we created two
separate models to understand both of
those things but in training a model for
bankruptcy we needed to figure out hey
who went bankrupt and turns out doing
that isn't always like the simplest
thing we had to ingest all this data
from a national bankruptcy database for
those of you that are familiar with with
Pacers and then you know match it up
with some of our in-house company names
but oftentimes the two aren't going to
say the exact same thing so there's like
this interesting matching problem that
we first had to tackle before training
these really fun models and actually I
was talking to Mike Moe earlier about a
talk that he had given in the last I
think it was like a year ago or around
that time for doing some of like this
addressing some of these fuzzy matching
problems with string matching and now
was just tremendously useful in figuring
it out for ourselves and we kind of came
up with our own in-house approach that
made sense for us and delivered on some
of the requirements that we had so I'll
walk you through that real quick of
course we have to clean our data convert
things to lowercase remove special
characters all that fun stuff
then I want to do the easy stuff first
so string matching and geo distance
great that stuff's hard and less you
know there's some uncertainty baked in
there but if I have a tax ID on both
sides of the fence I'm gonna use that if
we have a phone number on both sides of
the fence I'll use that then we get into
okay well you know this is Tom's
hardware and this is Tom's Hardware
without the apostrophe you know LLC or
something like that how do we know if
those are the same thing
well we can use all these different
string matching techniques things like
levenshtein distance things like your
winkler distance things like Jaccard
distance and you know there are lots of
others but those are the three main ones
that we used and then one thing that we
also employed in this kind of
hierarchical matching approach that I
thought was kind of unique is just
looking at the Geo distance between
these two different locations say one is
you know on Main Street in your town and
the other ones in Wilmington Delaware
you know a city where a lot of LLC's are
incorporated how do we know if that's
really the same thing basically what I
did is after going through like this
string matching process I allowed the
the Geo distance to have kind of a
multiplicative effect on that score and
kind of you know help us increase our
confidence that it's actually the the
same person or the same business entity
so a little pro tip quick tip down here
things like if you're if you're you know
rolling your own for something like
however sign distance or something like
that think about doing it in Saipan
first because without a great level of
effort you can you can do that and it's
going to be so much faster than if you
implement it in pure Python sure you
guys already know some of that a lot of
people touched on psyphon you know
throughout the last day and number four
if you're doing some you know numpy
operation or something like that it's
really easy to
that a function add your JIT decorator
and then you stand to benefit from the
just-in-time compilation there and we've
benchmarked these things and it's like
it's a big speed-up in a lot of cases so
what does that end up looking like so
you can see some you know different
companies here one of the names that the
name that came up on the bankruptcy and
the name that we had on file and some of
the string matching stats and the Geo
distance and then the score that they
ended up with so you know like this is
an interesting one innovative
construction solution NorCal vs.
innovative construction solutions you
know very similar obviously Geo distance
comes into play maybe this is like a
branch or something like that but you
know we felt pretty comfortable saying
hey this is the same entity so just a
quick fun fact about bankruptcy as it
applies to some of c2fo s suppliers a
lot of conventional wisdom kind of comes
out here when you see things like eating
places and hotels kind of bubbling to
the top as some of the most common
businesses that end up going bankrupt
and it's interesting to like pick apart
this trend over time you know generally
speaking you can see that fewer
businesses now are filing than were in
2009 and 2010 then when we look at this
heat map of the employee count on the
x-axis and then the company sales on the
y-axis perhaps you could draw a
conclusion that's a little bit
discouraging for an aspiring
entrepreneur and that is smaller
companies with less sales end up filing
for bankruptcy more often shocker right
but you actually see some of the the
bigger boys down here in the bottom
right hand corner filing - and I
apologize for this terrible color map
people on my team know that I'm like a
total stickler for like visualization
and stuff but no other color map really
kind of highlighted you know the these
differences over here as well as this
one did anyway moving on so now we need
to talk about fraud risk how do you know
that this that this supplier that you're
about to engage in this lending
agreement with is for lack of a better
term a good actor
okay how do you know that they're being
honest well we need to be able to sniff
that out and in in order to do that we
employ a couple different tricks when I
say tricks I don't really mean tricks
but we call it these suppliers we kind
of pitch them on this idea hey would you
like this you know really really
affordable loan blah blah blah this is
how we underwrite you you just need to
upload these other invoices from some of
your out-of-network supply buyers we're
recording those phone calls and we're
running some natural language processing
in the background and once we have that
transcription done then we can use
awesome libraries like Spacey to do some
of the limit ization tokenization etc
and we can do very simple things like
pick out words that way that we deem you
know potentially troublesome things like
debt leverage bankruptcy lien divorce
alcohol rollover audit Cayman Islands
right these are words that you do not
want to have high occurrence of and some
of those calls because it may be
indicative that they're not actually as
good of an actor as you would like them
to be so a pretty simple technique but
again very helpful how am i doing on
time
15 minutes good long story short this
wouldn't scale if we had somebody
sitting there doing it themselves so you
know this is something that we we wanted
to figure out early on another way that
we are kind of de-risking these
suppliers from a fraud standpoint is
this notion of invoice congruence so
that's to say that we're asking these
suppliers to upload their out-of-network
invoices but on the other side we have
you know the invoices that the buyers in
our markets uploaded so we can actually
compare them in terms of you know
amounts so that we can see hey what
they're uploading is it the same as what
that same buyer was showing us so we
know that they're not like patting her
in their invoices so sorry I kind of
went through that pretty quickly I know
about seven minutes left here so I want
a twenty five minutes
oh wow you can spend all the time we
want on this stuff
but you know having a conversation with
somebody and you know actually seeing
those invoices but having a source of
truth like that the invoices that we're
seeing from like our Costco market or
Amazon market turns out to be a really
good way of saying you know hey is this
is this particular supplier trustworthy
when you think about what maybe a bank
is relying on or maybe another lending
platform these are things like unaudited
financial statements that one are static
right so it's gonna be like a quarterly
statement from you know so many months
ago that probably didn't undergo a
rigorous audit and - you know so there's
there's the the piece that you can't vet
well and then there's also this piece
that you know that was a fixed point in
time how does that speak to you know
their ability to cover the terms of that
loan within this applicable you know
duration so the information that we have
you know hopefully it's pretty intuitive
by now helps us control some of these
risks so the last area that I kind of
want to talk about is portfolio
management so once we have all of these
suppliers in our portfolio that we're
willing to engage in lending agreements
with based on the fact that they have
diverse cash flows coming in from a
bunch of different buyers and we know
that you know they're not going to
default or go bankrupt in the next 45
days or something like that and we've
established that they're a good actor
based on the fact that their invoices
match up dollar for dollar with what our
buyers are uploading and that they're
not saying words like alcohol divorce
and Cayman Islands you know five six
seven times during the course of a phone
call we get all these suppliers in the
portfolio and then we need to think
about okay well how much should I
worship is tablished their credit credit
limit and at what rate you know should
we should I be charging them to to
borrow that amount in order to answer
those two questions we arrived at
what we call like a WFC score so you
guys are all familiar with your credit
score right a WFC score is basically on
a scale of 0 to 100 where we look at the
amalgamation of these different risk
factors that that I just talked through
and we come up with our opinion about
how trustworthy and how good of a
prospect for a lending agreement that
particular supplier might be so here you
see two distributions and we apply kind
of a trick to arrive at one of them so
this first distribution is you know all
of the suppliers that met all of our
criteria if you recall before I talked
about requiring up to five quarters of
historical information to make those
forecasts but what about the suppliers
that are relatively new on the c2fo
platform that we don't have that much
information for I'd still like to
appoint them with a score but since
that's one of the the underlying
variables you know we're just missing in
some cases so the trick was to train a
classifier right we have we have all of
this other information on them and we
have this like subset of the population
that is scored ok those become our our
labels you know that that WFC score is
just a continuous variable that we're
trying to predict and then we can use
everything else that we know about them
to kind of validate that score so you
know we're looking at you know an error
range of you know like plus or minus
like eight points or something like that
and you know within the context of what
we were trying to do that met certain
business requirements where we're
comfortable enough you know imputing
some of those WFC scores with that
strategy and that gives us complete
coverage with all of our hundreds of
thousands of suppliers in our network so
you know sometimes you when you think
creatively about how data is missing or
something like that oftentimes you can
you know get to a pretty good solution
if you're just kind of objective about
the problem from the get-go so talking
about calculating limits so the way we
calculate our credit limits
you remember those forecasts that I
showed you before let's do
go ahead and say that somebody has 20
million coming in the door over there
next sixty days or something like that
if they're in a top decile based on that
WFC score distribution then maybe we'll
say okay we're comfortable lending up to
80 percent of the cumulative sum of that
forecast over that duration okay if
they're in like a bottom decile well
maybe we won't even touch them we won't
prospect them for a loan but if there's
somewhere in the middle maybe we're not
comfortable going up to 80 percent but
maybe we're comfortable going up to 40
percent you know I won't tell you
explicitly what those ranges are but
it's kind of an intuitive idea the more
trustworthy they are the more
information we have have about that
supplier that can yield some kind of you
know competitive advantage for
underwriting them the more comfortable
we are giving them you know higher
credit limit
what's really interesting about how we
set rates we have kind of two different
strategies for doing that within the
context of the c2fo markets we
constantly have these suppliers bidding
in terms of APR or discount what they
would like or the discount that they
would be comfortable with to accelerate
payment on their accounts receivable so
we can kind of use what some of their
bids are within the c2fo markets as a
baseline for what their true cost of
borrowing might be in some cases they're
a little bit riskier than what they're
and they're bidding in the c2fo markets
so we can adjust for things like that
and in the event that they have never
placed a bid in the c2fo markets that's
when we start talking about you know
portfolio management theory and convex
optimization problems to arrive at you
know what the appropriate rate should be
for a given supplier if we want to
manage a portfolio with a risk profile
that looks like this or like that but
those are kind of the two approaches but
the fact that we have this really
interesting information from flowing
through from the c2fo markets that may
be indicative of what their true cost of
borrowing is really allows us to you
know let them borrow at rates that just
wouldn't be possible at other banks or
through other lending platforms so then
we think about who
we continue lending - so once you're in
the portfolio great you kind of checked
all these different boxes according to
our WFC underwriting criteria but just
because you're in the portfolio doesn't
mean you know and you you repay your
loan doesn't mean we should you know
keep reeling with the supplier and
continually engage in more and more
lending agreements with them so we look
at things like level shifts in their
accounts receivable patterns one of my
colleagues Eric bunch later today he'll
be talking about level shifts a package
that was initially developed developed
by Twitter for detecting level shifts
and time series has been ported over to
Python and he'll walk you through that a
little bit later today but suffice it to
say that we look for interesting jumps
in their in their time series of
accounts receivable to indicate that
something has changed something has
fundamentally shifted here that we need
to be mindful of and perhaps re
underwrite reevaluate etc we can look at
changes in the c2fo markets so if one
day somebody is bidding at 8% and then
tomorrow they're bidding at 18% perhaps
something changed overnight what's the
saying in Super Troopers desperation as
a stinky cologne or something like that
if we interpret that bid change as a
sign of desperation that is a very very
early indicator that that maybe we need
to rethink this thing WFC score changes
you know very intuitive there if some of
the the thing the variables that we
underwrite on shift over time and we see
that WFC score moving around if it has a
high volatility or if it goes from 80 to
60 one day that's something that's going
to be a big red flag for us adjustments
I mentioned before those are negative
outflows so when you see an
unprecedented adjustment and you kind of
wrap like a business understanding
around that maybe that means that a
buyer is returning a bunch of their
goods because they were defective maybe
that means that something else in that
relationship went wrong adjustments can
signal a lot of different things
sometimes they're just business as usual
but we're paying attention to the
adjustment to invoice ratio
so that when we do have unprecedented
adjustments that raises some red flags
and then we also have some other
interesting signals like bio reserves I
don't want to get into too much detail
about bio reserves but long story short
sometimes a buyer will reserve the
amounts of accounts payable that they
will allow a supplier in the c2fo
markets to accelerate and they do so for
different reasons but when you see a
buyer like Costco there who goes from
like a 10% reserve to like an 80%
reserve on a supplier like something
changed there and maybe that's an early
signal of distress as well that WFC
score over time I mentioned you know
that we're tracking it obviously so you
can kind of see here the time series of
that score on the bottom subplot in this
case you know it looks like they go from
you know the mid 70 is up to like the
low 80s on some days so not a ton of
movement but you can see you know like
their invoice discontinuation
probability over a 45 day window like it
jumped down on this day so maybe like
there was a big adjustment that came
through or something like that and the
model picked up on it you can see here
their junk score went down quite a bit
so that meant that a higher percentage
of their accounts receivable was coming
in from a supplier or a buyer rather
that we deemed junk you know by virtue
of having a low bond rating or something
like that so standing way back for a
second and kind of reevaluating the
whole big picture here of risk
management we talked about concentration
risk we talked about default risk fraud
risk exposure risk and and one way or
another and some of the unsystematic
risk that you face when you are managing
a portfolio of diverse suppliers that
you're engaging in you know lending
agreements with things that I didn't
mention along the way we talked about
how pandas was great for for cleaning up
those those time series and panels and
how we can pass you know pandas
dataframes to our pi2 we talked about
how stats models makes things like
seasonal decomposition really easy we
talked about how psych it is useful for
feature engineering and how we can use
libraries like XG boost to Train highly
performant classifiers but I didn't
really talk too much about like the
anaconda distribution and how easy that
makes certain things and I didn't really
talk about the extent to which this is
all you know built on a very very
complicated pipeline that has to run
every single evening accounting for new
invoices and adjustments looking for the
latest and greatest bankruptcy
information retraining models feeding
tying all of these different pieces
together to arrive at our very unique
opinion about you know whether or not
the suppliers worth lending to and you
know the other other quick shout out
here is is desk we're re-evaluating the
entire code base to look for areas that
kind of lend themselves to you know out
of core parallelization with with tasks
and we've already found you know a
couple different opportunities but in
time you know we'll look to incorporate
that you know in a lot of other ways so
here you can kind of see what our Luigi
dagger directed acyclic graph looks like
but I would like you guys to consider
something for a second if we were to
turn it upside down right you guys are
with me what does it look like maybe
kind of a Cobra and a basket I don't
know you tell me but you know just in
the theme of anaconda Python etc I'm
considering renaming this project
internally Cobra which sounds pretty
cool
so you be the judge all right cool I
talked about a lot of stuff demo time so
this is what the web app looks like for
those of you that are familiar with our
shiny you know a really simple and
intuitive web interface for you know
interacting with your data and there is
this really cool project that started
off called data spire now I think it's
just called spire that uses cherry pie
and Jinja to behind-the-scenes and is
just super maintainable for data science
we have like a very nice front-end that
the core c2fo product uses and very nice
front end for the WFC product and we
have a lot of really talented
you know angular developers and things
like that but for this tool it was the
onus was on the data science team to
build it and maintain it so I'm not a
front-end guy personally so I wanted to
use something that was you know easy to
understand easy to maintain etc and
spire just checked all of those boxes
for us so allowed us to do some simple
interactive things but also you know
maintain the code base and not go crazy
so just things like you know formatting
data frames down here showing our sweet
matplotlib forecast up here looking at
our forecast the seasonality plot that I
mentioned before the decomposition that
buyer breakdown so you can see how
diverse their accounts receivable are
their historical z'
historical WFC score rather some
supplemental information like okay this
particular supplier manufacturers ice
and was started in 1998 and then the
whole ranked list here of all the
different suppliers so you could just
grab one you know drop it in here and
look it up and then if you wanted to see
what you know their credit limit would
be you would have just adjust that
window for the duration
things would recalculate of course it's
gonna be painfully slow over my hot spot
and then you can see here that the
credit limit has adjusted based on that
new duration and then if you wanted to
download a spreadsheet that kind of
encapsulated all of this and just
kind of nice the picture we could go
ahead and do that that wasn't too bad
and you have all of that information you
know in one place for bookkeeping
purposes so quick easy cool practical
all of those things so what I like to
end kind of all of my talks and meetings
with this idea of just so what I talked
about all this stuff but at the end of
the day what does it all mean
I think objectivity is is really
important so we tried to approach this
this lending problem from a completely
objective place we didn't want to build
off of any of the things Lending Club
we're doing or any of the other guys we
wanted to use our data in a way that was
novel and purposeful for the ends that
we were trying to achieve and I think
things are working out really well so
far you've heard it before but better
independent usually beats more complex
algorithms the feature engineering
process can't stress how important that
is and the whole modeling process and
you know I encourage you all to you know
come up with new and interesting ways to
engineer those features we talked about
how siphon and numba can be used with
very little effort can be used to speed
up your code drastically in some cases
so somebody might have said oh why
didn't you write this system in you know
like like a go or something like that or
why didn't you write it in C++ or like a
know camel like you know the Jane Street
guys might have well again we wanted to
kind of play to our strong suits we
wanted we needed something that was
performant and you know Python kind of
check check those boxes for us for our
particular problem I mentioned that WFC
is a win win for borrowers and investors
the yield that you can achieve as an
investor is very attractive and we're
giving loans to suppliers that could not
be borrowing at that low of a rate from
a big bank or from some other lending
platform and when you think about you
know you
helping those businesses grow that's
that's a really cool thing to always be
mindful of trade offs you know when
you're engineering a system a complex
system especially from the ground up how
fast is fast enough
do I want to would I want to maintain
this code a year from now two years from
now three years from now I talked a
little bit of before about you know do
you need a beautiful front-end or
something that's simply functional and
readily extensible these are all things
that you really need to you know look
deep within yourself and you know ask
before creating a ton of technical debt
and last but not least creating great
solutions with open-source is part of
open source too sometimes you can get
really caught up on you know obviously
to keep the community alive and well you
need people actively contributing and
cross pollinating ideas but you also
need to be building really great things
using that software to kind of keep the
momentum and the trajectory headed in
the right direction as well so with that
thank you very much and here to answer
any questions that you may have
yes so the first question was how do we
address a kind of look ahead bias so
I'll talk about that in two different
lights the first piece is kind of with
those forecasts so we want to create
this great forecast for the next 90 days
so what we'll do is pretend like we
didn't see you know the last 90 days
train a model up until that point and
then evaluate all of these different
forecasts against what actually came to
fruition over the course of those 90
days seeking to minimize the things that
I mentioned before may rmse etc so
whichever model kind of minimizes those
things over that backtest period will
promote to the best model for the next
90 days so within a forecasting context
you know that's kind of how we think
about it so at the AAP discontinuation
stuff or the AR discontinuation stuff
rather similarly you know if we wanted
to make a prediction today were if we
were going to engage in a lending
agreement with somebody today ideally we
would like to know 45 90 180 80 days in
advance that their likelihood of
discontinuation is is high so we would
truncate you know that window of time
and then we would train our models based
on you know that which would have been
observable at the time that we would
have liked to make that prediction so
that we wouldn't have engaged in a
lending agreement with them within that
window of time so it's kind of like
hiding what wouldn't have been
observable at the time
no I did I did write some gnarly
functions to do that for us which I
would be glad to share there if they're
useful but basically something like you
would you would pass in a time series
you would pass in you know like a window
that a prediction window like 45-day
window or something like that that you
that you need to truncate that data then
it does some injection in like a sequel
query and allows you to you know get
that data back in a nice kind of clean
panel with your with your class label
based on what actually happened over the
course of that that prediction window
I'm trying to trying to make it a little
bit more you know universally usable and
you know that's something I'd like to
open-source over time if it would be
useful and then I believe you had a
second question as well
oh the security aspect yeah so our
suppliers data is you know very very
important to us and you know I made a
point to obfuscate everything related to
those suppliers so that we can you know
keep that private as it should be
but at the same time that same
information is very useful for us for
prospecting some of these suppliers and
you know giving them the opportunity to
borrow at these very agreeable rates so
yeah it's of the utmost concern always
to keep that data private as it should
be all right if there any other
questions be glad to talk to you outside
and I just like to thank everybody again
thanks
you